if I was asked to Define woke I would
say that it's a cult or a secular
religion which teaches that Society is
systemically oppressive towards certain
supposedly marginalized groups the cult
believes that our institutions were
built expressly with the purpose of
oppressing these groups and the only way
to combat the oppression is to tear down
the institutions and restructure them
according to the doctrines of the cult
nothing can exist for its own sakes no
institution can have any purpose above
or beyond the enforcement of those
doctrines the ultimate goal according to
the cult is equity and Equity simply
means that the imagined oppression of
their favored groups has been
counteracted by policies that
artificially Elevate those same groups
and of course in the woke religion the
Satan figure is the heterosexual white
male and each member of this group
inherits the collective guilt of the
oppressor